Oi e agora convosco humorista Ricardo
violão
E aí
Oi
bom dia
na sempre uma pizza não é tão mas tão
bom dia muito obrigado até se pelo pelo
convite vivos uma energia muito especial
nesta sala tá muito estamos locação de
energia isso nós aqui estamos a fazer a
pessoas não têm energia que acabamos
todos
em alguns gostaram da ideia mais que os
outros
em casa de Espetacular amanhã no jornal
de Leiria sad acaba inglês
e a próxima tem os americanos nenhum
Wesley Borges
queremos abrir o slot sim daquele Borges
significa vamos lá pessoal é
hoje eu vim aqui fazer uma espécie de
pessoa ou falta muito pouco a certas
pessoas completamente cheio é verdade
que há três ou quatro lugares vazios mas
isso são pessoas que se deparam com
muita antecedência
e eu tento faleceram
Ah e não vieram a
e neste momento estou aqui mais do que
no estádio de Leiria desde foi
construído em
e parabéns a terra eu vim aqui fazer uma
espécie de resumo
foram entrevistas muito interessantes
isso Não falhar no que havia Fonseca
falou Adorei o que se fartam de fazer e
fiquei com uma dúvida em relação aos eu
não sei se alguém precisa de sócios para
a empresa de vinhos
e essa espertamente muito amor o vinho
o e todos deram contribuições muito
importantes em cima tudo acho que uma
coisa que foi comum a todos os oradores
eu vios local desde às sete da manhã
eu cai Liria
falaram com o coração falaram daquilo
que os move e falaram
e com a preocupação da linguagem mas sem
estarem preocupados ou demasiado
preocupados em parecer bem eu acho que é
isso que nos falta muitas vezes é que
nós e perdemos a capacidade de
dizer realmente aquilo que achamos e
procuramos demasiado forma e quando um
diante eu sou obrigado a trabalhar com
limites tanto de linguagem como o Bom
Gosto EA reta porque piada está sempre
no limite e estão é que não vamos ao
limite não tem graça e a pouco tempo
aprendi uma grande lição queria
partilhar convosco em relação aos
limites eu fui fazer um evento de
solidariedade essa é outra coisa que eu
acho que é importante é sermos
solidários uns com os outros e eu gosto
muito fazer eventos LTDA ME pagam
o e fui fazer que estiver de
solidariedade e era um evento
solidariedade para a África
foi na margem sul de Lisboa
o que faz sentido a
e eu pensei Ok vamos lá vamos ajudar é
uma causa que me diz bastante tenho
monte de família África
fugiram por lá
eu
vou fazer este evento solidariedade e
vou fazer gente solidariedade para
ajudar o objetivo é enviar um contentor
e não devemos vazio umas enviamos
e eu vou fazer espero aqui para fazer na
boca vou fazer porque é contribuir com
aquela calça Ok e Acontece uma coisa que
foi das maiores lições da minha carreira
enquanto um dia antes enquanto o homem
tá mesmo
e eu entro em Portugal e quando estou
local às tantas no camarim não como
sempre e foi o presidente dessa
Associação e disse rigorosamente o
padrão de verdade Olha o violão não faça
piadas sobre o coiso
e eu sempre sobre negros
mais negros ou pretos cinzas o homem não
sabia bem como dizer eu pensei calma
assim eu não sou racista eu não vou não
sexista não fosse novo até que não sei o
que significa
aí eu fui ali fazer aquele evento fui lá
de Bora lá por umas anos depois a gente
fazer aquele evento é óbvio que eu não
sou racista por carga de água e o pior
resto podem A pior coisa que pode ser um
dia a gente vai rebola e não faz piadas
sobre isto que a partir daquele momento
da minha cabeça será pim-pam-pum ligada
a batata um lá em cima no amor tem um
campo estava a pensar faltava três
minutos que queria me matar e
E aí
E aí ele tava bloqueado eu não sei se
você sabe o que é que significa isso que
teve marca vai querer voar e quer saber
que significa esses grãos úmidos nada
é bonito pa pule pule a contribuir para
aquela causa na boa e pensa com três
meses e eu vou eu vou vos reproduzir
como é que foi a minha entrada em palco
aí eu estou aqui imagina se fosse
perguntar a algum lugar mas não faltam
três minutos quando começa a voz alta e
o quando entrar estava fazer isso
receber isso aí fique com Deus ou se eu
tivesse entrado Água Limpa qualquer até
agora não estou aqui
E aí o
esporte é isso aqui não é eu vou já
começa e o Pimpão Caraguá minhas
senhoras e meus senhores sejam
bem-vindos este espectáculo de
solidariedade para África como Vasco o
melhor comediante do mundo
o tipos de geralmente a
o Google os nossos convidados Ricardo
leilão
E aí
o primeiro as duas coisas por aí com
meus amigos muito obrigado por este
convite se por acaso eu disse alguma
coisa para ofender não usa essa faca tem
no bolso aqui ó
e já agora mais uma cena de um bocado
Gustavo é desculpa ou menos ó
como vocês viram se eles partiram ser
repetitivo a maior gargalhada toda a
minha carreira foi um espetáculo que
eles perceberam que não é eu estava
apenas a brincar não ser racista e não
brincar com as coisas que posso sempre
brincar eles receberam as pessoas
percebem Se nós formos sinceros as suas
percebe o placar de fundos melhor
espetáculo e muitos aplausos municipal
mas no fim vieram abraçaram e beijaram
deram uma facada e foram vida deles
e não é ficar de olho fui fazer é
composto Boa noite vou botar o